foreign
was given to the Wolves and the Wolves
were running with it one side's feeding
you a plate while the other side is
giving you a free sample of dope a lot
of these people are even grandparents
that are out here that are smoking crack
that are doing heroin
there's got to be some kind of break in
the system
Ground Zero of our local heroin epidemic
lies in the heart of Philadelphia's
Kensington section Kensington the drugs
were the motive for shooting in
Kensington this morning their drug users
from all over line the streets and
makeshift area in Kensington out this
Haven for drug addicts Don heroin in
Kensington round zero
he's on the front lines of the nation's
heroin epidemic with evidence of battles
lost scattered like wings that's big
results in Kensington struggling with
drug addiction May soon have a place to
safely inject themselves drug abuse in
Kensington is just not hard to find
opioid crisis is far from over
my name is Dennis Payne I am the founder
of the eye of Kensington on Facebook and
you are standing here in Kensington at
Quickie Stop in front of McPherson
Square the famous needlepoint Park where
everything drug related is taking place
the best way I can describe Kensington
is it's a war zone it's two types of War
zones you've got a spiritual for the
religious people that are concerned and
then you've got the physical
non-religious which is all drug and
crime related
Kensington was given to the Wolves and
the wolves are running with it
and it's a dead land there there's no
good anything here anymore in Kensington
it's all slowly dying
you shouldn't be afraid America to come
down here because it's your sons and
daughters that are out here
you know I mean a lot of these people
are even grandparents are out here that
are smoking crack that are doing heroin
and they're not even really doing real
heroin there ain't real opiate out here
it's mainly tranq or fentanyl
these people are mentally and physically
disabled so you've got to come out and
look at these guys as infantile treat
them like little kids don't be afraid of
them you know we all had that terrible
two child this is the terrible twos and
it's worse at its worse they're they're
very infantile a lot of them are are are
very extremely harmless until provoked
right and they're easily provoked you
know when they're hungry when they're
cold they're going to be angry so
therefore they live that lifestyle
constantly so they're going to be
constantly angry so what you're seeing
is not really them you're what you're
seeing is the results of a very rough
life these guys are the guys for use
Christians you're supposed to be out
here getting them sheltered not giving
them a tuna fish sandwich and leaving
the you know your rappers
I don't see homeless people out here
they're not in this area most people in
this area have some kind of mental
physical or drug addiction they see all
the services coming here so they migrate
here right they need to be you know
taken care of taken off the streets
there's no reason for somebody who's
mentally and physically disabled be and
being out here doing drugs especially
the way they got to get the drugs get
the money to get the drugs they're
breaking you know all kinds of laws I
don't need to tell you what they're
doing just look at our police logs
right now this is only for the users and
the dealers the other day up at k a
you're in a food line one side's feeding
you a plate why the other side is giving
you a free sample of dope this is the
stuff that's got to stop by feeding
these people you're giving the other
people cover to do their thing to keep
these people addicted and that's the
system that's got to stop there's got to
be some kind of break in the system